condition a very ill condition and one
day i received
another one dying flower after like
december 2018 and just to remind me what
the dying flower what does it symbolize
what does it mean the one the rose you
know the the ross
i mean the emoji the emoji what does it
what does it mean that if you get a
dying flower what does that indicate
uh some i mean the chinese government
touched my family members
okay okay the emoji
meaning they arrested them yes i mean
of course only the thing is arrested by
the chinese government you got the point
on it actually
i don't want to tell what they call the
spirituality part actually
everything i saw in my dream also i
don't want to tell this part because i
don't want to
uh people oh no i think we need to hear
this one brother please
yeah actually just one day before my
father
is like from the high and he's the
falling down then
i like you know uh even the ones just
now
this is my dream in no actually just now
also i i my dream my shortening just now
when i come to the malaysia when i told
you just now
when i was from malaysia in my dream
also someone ordered me
out from malaysia before saturday in my
dream
subhanallah yes yes so allah saved me
actually
you know this is what happened i mean
end of 2017
my flight is on sunday but someone
ordered me
in my dream very clearly you held out
from malaysia before saturday
here you know the prophet muhammed he
told us that you can have a
an actual dream which indicates the
future you know and this is
the the ulama of islam they've divided
dreams into different types and one of
them is
the actual true dream that tells you
about the truth the future
and this is unbelievable what you're
saying to me right now is it's
phenomenal like you know subhanallah
that shows you that allah subhanahu wa
he has given you subhanallah a mission
in life
you have you've been chosen for this
mission brother
yes yes yes yes that is exactly what i'm
thinking you know brother why allah
saved me you know
because i have to answer to allah when
your nation
actually i tell you later on all the
mosque in my village is
being demolished i tell you after this
this one you know so i got everything
so meaning that uh you know if i don't
do anything
i will questionable or i have to answer
to allah what i did when i save you
from this the red evils you know so
actually
uh that's why i don't want to make it
very spiritual but
i know this part is very touchy part as
well so
anyway when it's come to my father in my
dream
my father is falling down forever from
very high
then is he's just like struggling in my
dream then
uh i just like you know again
i got some message to someone then and
he told me one dying flower
emoji okay emoji so meaning that they
arrested
my father as well then when i contacted
that chinese officials they already like
delisted me in the wechat
because i cannot send him the message
anymore
and then i i purchased the international
call
then i called him again then i told him
now you arrested my father
you have to release them actually don't
underestimate
my power as well i'm very popular in
malaysia
and also uh i mean uh what they call is
so you're telling me you're telling me
sorry doctor sorry let me just say
something here and this is so important
for us
okay yes yes you're telling me that
with your influence yeah as an academic
someone who has access to the media that
you
are able to get the chinese government
direct to release your family members
with that kind of threat
yes yes yes yes
then then you've given us a key here you
have given us a key
yes this is exactly it shows you know
what this shows you
doctor sorry just to because it's not a
problem no problem
it shows us the extent to which the
chinese government are fragile yes
and it shows us how much impact is
possibly had exactly exactly
is watching this right now that if we
come together and use our social media
influence
just our social media yes yes yes you
can influence i mean if you did it and
you could get
three people out of prison at different
times imagine if
all did it how many yes yes yes
yes yes yes because chinese government
nature like this if you are like scared
from them
they want to bully you but if you are
strong enough
then they step back you know something
like that so this is the nature of it
this is life this is life yes this is
the life yes
then after that uh you know
my my life is in struggle then they
released me my father
and after that uh i mean i got a
national award
from in december 2018 i got the national
award from turkey
and it is presented by president of the
turkey region
as well so i mean that is something
i i i saw this picture is this you yes
yes yes yes brother yes brother yes yes
yes so meaning that after that i think
they didn't touch my parents they didn't
touch my sister
they didn't touch my uh brother as well
because i have the
one younger brother as well so meaning
that uh
starting from then uh but i mean my
sister is disappeared for
few months i think they did they
arrested him they arrested her again
uh then i think but is uh disappeared
like for
four four four five months then after
that the pressure of international
community
i think they released some people from
the concentration camp
then that time i think they released my
sister as well
so meaning that in order to save my
sister again
so i i continued my journey actually so
meaning that
uh because you know then i'm asking
myself
okay it's not about my father it's not
my
about my father actually in order to
save
a people my people or in order to save
the islam in sacrifice
my father or my mother you know this is
i mean
in order to i mean they i mean i know
actually
now they're at home uh to be honest i'm
100 sure they're at home
uh now right now but you know the
problem is now
more than the issue is more than my
family right now actually
because what they're called i have to
say i am
completely taken aback by your story i
i you i rarely ever use a word like this
but you have
professor you have a heroic story you
have an
absolutely heroic story and it's amazing
and it's a privilege for me
to hear this i mean i genuinely
read about stories like this in history
books i i'd rarely ever get a chance to
speak to someone who's been through what
you've been through
and done what you've done and you've
given us
so much hope actually i i want you to
know that you have given us so much hope
and you've given us their weak points
i mean is this the sense that you can do
this yes
we have a lot of social media influence
yes we thrilled and this is the message
i know the chinese government
i know the chinese government is
watching this yes yes
unconditionally for all of the
prisoners to be taken out of the chinese
prisons and that if you don't we will
start a movement which will become so
powerful yes and it knows exactly what
china
is doing that believe you me it will not
just be written in the history books
it will be written everywhere that the
chinese government
is the most brutal and barbaric and
megalomaniacal diabolical government
that has
ever you know dealt with a minority
group and is ever
doing so now and believe you me
you know with your support it will not
just be insha'allah with the will of
allah
your parents and your sister and your
family
who will be assured safety in istanbul
pakistan but it will be the entire
muslim population
and this has become our struggle now
you're struggling no longer your
struggle
i want to let you know dr bolham thank
you so much
yes every single person who is watching
this stream now is already
a front line worker
every single one of us now are with you
i don't want you to feel for a second
that you're alone
thank you so much brother thank you so
much every single person that's watching
this stream and the thousands that are
going to watch you after is done
we are all with you and we will do
whatever is needed
and whatever is required through the
legal systems
and so yes necessary yes yes
legal means necessary yes required
to free the people of east pakistan yeah
thank you
thank you social media activism make a
difference
is it important for people to do of
course
definitely every time there is what they
call is
like very strong voice from
international community i mean
i mean this chinese government is really
liar you know
uh if they say there is no the the what
they call
the mos masjid is being the claws and
they just try to show one
to the mosque i mean as open they just
try to tell them
the mosque is being opened and also we
say
i mean they tried to senizing our people
then the next day they were showing
okay some uh people singing the uyghur
song you know so meaning that
of course this is the pressure of
international community so meaning that
if we do something in the social media
of course
we can influence by the chinese
government as well
so that's why uh even uh some people
is protesting in what they call in the
uh in front of chinese embassy
and the chinese government called them
don't go to the protest
we will let you to your you can talk to
your with your parents you know this has
happened to
many fam family members as well actually
actually
they want to stop me as well by showing
my father and my mother
i told them you know now is you cannot
stop me anymore
okay my my father already like 70 years
old my father my mother already 60 plus
okay now they live enough already
okay i mean actually by this way
okay put me this way brother they want
to
i mean they don't want to let the people
to top this issue they don't want to let
uh not they're not allowed to advocate
for them yes you are making
such a sacrifice by being an activist
and there's so many of us that we don't
have to make any sacrifice
and we'll be activists thank you thank
you thank you
for the muslim community actually to be
honest with you
it's a huge shame on the muslim it's the
biggest where are the scholars
yes yes so why are they talking about
wiping over the sock and who is an
innovator
nowadays people are dying these
people are all called muslim scholars
and speakers and
there are people with huge reaches huge
absolutely
huge you're telling us you've said today
that you threatened the chinese
government
with with with the international media
and they released your family no one is
threatening
our family members we could do it free
of charge
without danger living in the west
it's unbelievable that the muslim
community
is so caught up in unprioritized things
that we cannot even see that there is a
holocaust a genocide
an infiltration they're wiping away
a population a demographic destroying
mosques
50 mosques you said there were 50
mosques in your village just imagine
it's just in my village so you can
imagine in the whole easter
how many mosques they're being
demolished that is that
something is unbelievable unbelievable
we really have a job to do believe we
are your comrades we are your brothers
in faith we will help you
we will do as much as we
who have the ability to but are choosing
to
de-prioritize this issue for all of the
other issues
it's for anybody that calls themself an
influencer in the muslim world
or in fact anyone who cares about human
life
for this yes yes the top of their
priorities list
yes yes so yeah uh so
that's why uh maybe what you can do just
now brother suburu also asking
also maybe also i request you
if you do if you can do actually you can
organize protest in from chinese embassy
as well
there's civil society yeah civil society
in turkey also
joining our protest actually so meaning
that actually yes
uh maybe of course now the thanks for
canada thanks for the netherlands as
well
uh saw them declared as a genocide so
now is a chinese government is like
uh i mean under a pressure as well so
meaning that
we ask you also uh maybe someone in
germany or someone in
other part of the europe actually our
people already started like
long much of the protest in the
different ambassadors
what we have and we want to raise
awareness for this we have an
organization now
it's called the weaker freedom
organization
with more than 100 links to universities
across the world
and we are mobilizing and this is our
message
exactly right our legal threat to the
training
thank you so much i know they're
watching me yes
yes you should be quaking you should be
shaking
because we are gonna expose you
we are going to expose you is going to
be the new
germany yes you know
the chinese communist party will be the
new nazi party
we have the ability to make that be the
case
the only demand we have is that
the state of east africa become
an independent state we don't care about
anything else
in our business the dustbins of history
the chinese government i am threatening
you
with the most legal and the most
influential of ways
people are going to see we are going to
expose you
we are going to humiliate you we are
going to discombobulate you
we are going to bedazzle the chinese
people and the muslim soldiers here
that are ready and i mean that in the
metaphorical sense
the soldiers the comrades all of those
people that are on this chat
we are with you hand in hand dr burhan
and we will march
to the left to the right in front we
will be as a group
inshallah
and your story it will be
a catalyst it will be an absolute
catalyst
for what we will do as the muslim
community and as i say
it's no longer an option i'm saying this
to every single person with influence
it's especially in my own community the
muslim community
listen carefully it is no longer an
option for you to stay silent on these
issues
and for you to not utilize your
platforms
and for you to not mobilize and join
the struggle where masjids are being
destroyed
50 masjids in a small town with 10
000 people we're hearing it live with a
primary resource example
it's no longer an option and we will not
tolerate it anymore
and we are with you 100 so use us
like i'm like the sahaba used to say
i'm gonna ask he said we are your we
are your bow we are your arrow
we are your arrow so shoot us in the
direction that you want
we will be shocked and the chinese
government now
you have only one option you have only
one option
is to go back to 1933 agreements
and to make this east turkestan which
constitutes a sixth of the
land mass of china into a state of its
own
yes that's the only thing we're going to
accept absolutely
and in fact you know else you better
release every single prisoner
and stop sterilizing 87
of women in that area because you can
try and sterilize us
you can try and change our language you
can even try and stop us speaking
and read in the quran but you cannot
destroy the
iman the faith that we have in our
hearts and you
this this dr who allah sent
dreams to to tell him
to show him the way this is an amazing
karamah that allah has sent to this man
to tell him that his father something is
going to happen to him to make a move
this is no coincidence that dream was no
joke
that dream turned out to be true and
today you are here
telling us and believe you me the people
are hearing
and there will be the biggest snowball
effect that we can
ever imagine there's a lot of
impassioned people like me
who will take this initiative and drive
it forward
to the next of the chinese governments
and they will listen
and we will crush them intellectually
and through any propaganda means there
is no
more playing around the muslims
in the west who are the most influential
in this
have now stood up and we are all going
to
march forward and create huge change
and whatever is in our legal abilities
to do
we are willing to sacrifice anything
money and anything
in order to advance our course
absolutely
absolutely thank you so much and as you
can see
the freedom organization we're with you
inshallah in fact i'm actually thinking
one the lockdown's over me and muhammad
hijab we can come down to turkey we can
meet you we can
thank you so much brother you know i
just my last word i want to say to
brother muhammad you know just now there
is a story of the pro
during the prophet sallam one person
beating
his wife you know always beat the wife
then i mean
she came to complain i mean uh i mean
uh they're beating their wife always
they beat the wife you know
then prophet allah told them just tell
the neighborhood
okay he's beating the wife so meaning
that after that you know
uh that man is stop beating uh his wife
because of i mean the
neighbors you know you know so this is
exactly we can apply to the chinese
government actually
so meaning that they're beating the
people if you keep silent
they beat more and more actually
definitely inspirational and insha allah
one day we will pray
in mosque in sha allah
and when we will see a free east
turkestan we will know the promise of
allah
is indeed true thank you so much first
brothers i appreciate it
thank you brother